[Applauso]
[Musica]
che dite
[Applauso]
siamo tornati un po indietro nel nostro
percorso
ne abbiamo conosciuto questa musica
attraverso il cinema il cinema di woody
allen ci ha veramente cambiato la vita
abbiamo visto un film si chiama midnight
in paris ve lo ricorderete probabilmente
e ci ha portato in un mondo fantastico
in un mondo in cui la musica e
soprattutto i sogni venivano vissuti in
una maniera alternativa
allora abbiamo iniziato il nostro
percorso musicale nella maniera più
semplice andando in via lagrange
vincendo torino a suonare in strada un
po nel nostro percorso artistico
abbiamo notato che la musica ragazzi per
noi almeno per come la viviamo è un
linguaggio sapete è un modo di
esprimersi le persone che incontriamo
nella nostra vita almeno per quanto ci
riguarda sono il vero investimento
quello che non ti tradisce mai quello
che quando la sera vai a dormire
te lo porti dietro e ti porti dietro che
cosa
l'emozione e alla fine va a toccare
proprio quelle corde quelle corde che
sono dentro di noi laggiù nascoste che
sono in assoluto luogo più sicuro quello
che vi vogliamo raccontare questa sera
con la nostra musica che semplicemente
un po riassunto di questa nostra teoria
applicata e il fatto che avere una
passione nella vita avere un sogno è una
cosa veramente molto importante è anche
se viviamo in un mondo dove molto spesso
qualcuno ci dice di lasciare stare
perché a volte ci sono cose piu pratiche
nella vita quelle cose più standard che
mettono tutti d'accordo non vi vogliamo
dire non gli date retta
tenete stretti i vostri sogni è andata
avanti la nostra musica nasce da quello
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]
salutiamo con l'ultimo brano che ha
permesso di connetterci non solo con i
sessi ma con la natura
abbiamo siamo con i sì con le lucciole
sapete che con gli animaletti che si
accendono e si spengono una sera siamo
improvvisati scienziati ci siamo chiesti
ma le lucciole sanno andare a tempo di
musica così a caso abbiamo scoperto che
le lucciole non solo andassero a tempo
ma andassero più a tempo di noi quindi
era immancabile scrivere un brano
dedicato in realtà alla danza notturno
di queste lucciole meravigliose che
stavano sull'acqua di un lago e si
riflettevano un po come fossimo nel film
big fish
bisogna far fly
[Musica]
aiuto
[Applauso]
[Musica]